so yeah for you guys
your philosophy because the philosophy
with women with men with dating with
marriage with kids with money with
finance with health everything it's
inspired through certain things you talk
about the mystery you talk about the
pickup artist the book the game all of
that and then you know what you did in
college when you kind of learned a
little bit about the game three years
ago you come to miami
who had the biggest influence on your
philosophy and what is really the core
foundation of your philosophy um you
know shout out to our guy rolo tomasi
man good friend of ours the rational
male obviously was was a great book it
uh you know connected a lot of dots for
me personally um and then you know if
you because the thing is with the you
know the mystery method fantastic book
gives you a great insight as to you know
how female psychology works when it
comes to attraction and what they're
aroused by but you know a lot of the
techniques in that book are a bit dated
you know we're talking about using can
openers doing cold approaches in the
club and bar um you know we live i mean
that phone came out i'm sorry well that
book came out in the early early 2000s
before cell phones everything else like
that so the game has obviously changed
but the fundamentals are still the same
when it comes to what is attractive to
women so um basically like from taking
that knowledge from taking the you know
the the red pill awareness from reading
obviously like the rationale whatever it
connected a lot of dots for me that i
already knew and um you know kind of put
things in perspective but you know we
kind of have our own strategy on how we
deal with things because you know times
have changed you know the data
marketplace has changed significantly uh
versus you know 20 years ago thanks to
the smartphone and technology and
everything else like that so we kind of
have a different spin on how we operate
and how we deal with women in general
with the modern day marketplace but yeah
yeah me personally regarding um my
influence would be experience because uh
i watch and i learn so ask questions so
i'll see people like how do you get this
girl how does he have in this car how's
having his lifestyle ask questions and
from there i applied to myself and i
learned from experience and also as well
yeah
so
yeah so but what are the core
foundations so give me an idea what some
of your philosophies are so i the
biggest thing that i tell guys is um you
got to put yourself first right like you
got to put like your mission first like
because if you if you put women first a
lot of guys are you know more concerned
with like uh could we swear i don't know
if i should okay okay a lot of guys are
more concerned like jason ass versus
like you know chasing success and yeah
that's great you know obviously you know
you got to play the volume game talk to
a lot of girls whatever but the problem
is that your retention level is not
going to be that high when you don't
have your stuff together you know what
i'm saying if you really want to be like
the best man that you can be you want to
be the best man that you can be and then
have women be a byproduct of it versus
chasing the women like yeah you'll get a
lot of girls from going out and cold
approaching all day and all that other
stuff but are you going to be able to
retain them and most importantly get
them to respect you and what i've
learned from dealing with you know at
this point we've interviewed like a
thousand girls on our show
respect is a foundation and that respect
doesn't come from unless you're i always
say uh competence leads to
accomplishments which leads to um
confidence and then that confidence is
what the girl respects because you've
already built a foundation upon from
that confidence and that confidence in
government then here you know girls say
all the time i want confidence i want
confidence translation and woman ease i
want someone that's established and able
to assert his will on the world and i
want to be able to follow that man's
leader and that comes from your success
say those three things again uh
so you got competence leads to
accomplishments which then leads to
confidence and that's what the girls are
attracted to is that confidence and but
that confidence has got to be genuine
that's why we tell guys all the time you
got to be congruent to who you are
because if you're congruent to who you
are girls are going to be able to notice
you know women have way more um
a better perception of social
calibration than men do so they're going
to be able to tell if you're about it or
not you know you can play the game for a
bit but if you're cap eventually they're
going to figure it out so if you're
really about it and you're that guy
she's going to be attracted to you
because you have that confidence from
your accomplishments so that's what we
tell guys is focus on yourself because
it's inherently going to make you
attractive in the first place and then
second on top of that you're going to be
winning and then women are a byproduct
of success versus chasing the women and
making them the metric obsession so far
what's controversial so far i'm sure
so where do we haven't gotten that yeah
okay so where do people because what you
just said is
uh uh
you have you have two choices right you
have a choice to
uh uh uh date women through desperation
which is what a lot of guys do yeah or
you have a way to manage expectation by
setting the tone on what kind of value
you bring to the marketplace then your
pool and your options widens yeah that's
just how it works right okay same thing
works with uh
business as well if you if your business
is predicated based on one client you
are screwed you're slave to that one
client
but if your business is you have
multiple options you have you know you
can have a little bit more leverage and
you actually offer better customer
service when you are because you're not
you're not leading that customer based
on desperation you're not begging them
they feel confidence from you if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]
you